[Music]
hello hello everybody and welcome to
another episode of the after show today
we are going to be talking about the one
the only Dwayne The Rock Johnson and his
movie that I might have enjoyed called
Black Adam we love him we love what he's
cooking whenever he cooks anything but
listen we're gonna be breaking down the
movie we're gonna be diving into all the
details and then we're going to be
talking about of course what we always
talk about and that is where does this
film leave us what's the future of this
film what's the future of of the Black
Adam now franchise that The Rock has
already said we're gonna have and the
DCU you have two choices
you can be the destroyer of this world
or you can be its savior
that's up to you
so who better
to talk about Black Adam than Dwayne
Johnson just kidding
Mike Kalinowski how are you he's an
author he's an actor thank you so much
for joining I'm glad you got the wearing
the black memo but my my pleasure my
pleasure well I heard I was going to be
co-starring with the rock as well on
this so there's nothing I can do I
figure maybe a black T-shirt where's
your chain Dude where's your chain I
don't have any jewelry I should have
pulled something out of the closet I
think I think I would have pulled it off
looking more like Mr T the need it looks
his uh chain there no man jewelry that's
okay I'm totally on board with that this
of course was a look from way back when
um so before we dive into it I'm going
to point out that there is a big
discrepancy in the Tomato Meter score
and the audience score the Tomato Meter
score being 39
and the audience score being 90 I think
that's the biggest difference in any of
the after shows I've ever covered but
here is the critics consensus they said
Black Adam may end up pointing the way
to an exciting future for DC films but
as a standalone experience it is a
wildly uneven let down so before we go
into all the details overall Mike did
you smell what The Rock was cooking or
did you not which is a metaphor for did
you overall enjoy the film or not enjoy
the film I think I I think I always
smell what The Rock is cooking now do I
leave satisfied after the meal
um I'll say this I did smell what The
Rock was cooking okay I though didn't
feel the hierarchy of power changed in
the dceu like he was claiming for years
now with this
so I'm somewhere in the middle of the
audience score and the critics score
somewhere
maybe like in the 60 70.
area a little better than halfway
through it I I have thoughts I have
thoughts I guess we can talk about we
will talk about it I overall enjoyed the
pants off this movie I had such a good
time with it and I did I'm gonna put it
out there I did see it late I normally
go to see critic screenings and then the
audience you know reception filters in
and because I think because of the
Rotten Tomato score I went into it with
absolutely no expectations I went in
hearing like the story was so all over
the place and bad and like you know I
just heard so many negative critic
things but I want to point out something
Mike I want to know if you agree with me
or not because what I see a lot online
is people saying oh don't listen to the
critics this was an amazing movie I
think both things can exist at the same
time I think you can have a movie that
by a critical perspective when you talk
about critics they see 200 300 movies a
year from a critics perspective maybe it
was a 39 but from an audience
perspective it still can be a really
great fun movie both can be true do you
agree or do you think they should be
more cohesion between the two scores
uh I'm I think 100 with you on that
um it's surprising this past week I've
seen on Twitter because my kind of
Circle of Friends is all in the film and
a lot of our pundits and I find that
such a disservice to what critics do you
know they're a lot of people rely on
critics reviews you know they they don't
see 40 50 movies a year uh they gotta
kind of
spend their money where they want to and
get a Critic score but I also feel
it's tough because that people go to
school for critic being a Critic and
they have such an Insight a lot of times
especially when it comes to even DC
films they pick up stuff that I don't
ever think about
um but also there is something to be
said about you know just going to a
movie and enjoying it like just like you
said you have no expectations going in
and I think that's a problem with these
superhero films now we're getting to the
point where if it doesn't tell you know
connect to five stories before it and
give us five stories Beyond it you're
like wow this story was lacking and
sometimes you just go in like I think I
was the same as you I didn't see a
Critic screening I just wanted to go in
no expectations and for me the character
of Black Adam was never a great
character uh a fan of mine I was never a
big fan of it so I wasn't like I've got
to see this I've got to see this for me
I think it was more the JSA and of
course Pierce Brosnan knowing when he
would attached to this film
um so I went in for that and on that end
I left completely satisfied with with
Pierce Bros and and but what of the JSA
they gave us so are you a so you're a
comic fan so so when you say like you
weren't super interested in that
character what about him because what I
thought was interesting was and The Rock
talked about this he is so charismatic
as a person but from what I understand
and you can tell me if I'm wrong the
character of Black Adam isn't supposed
to be a super charismatic person he's
very sort of Inward and sort of brooding
and he definitely did that but I think
we're always Expecting The Rock to be
the Rock and he didn't do that and it
felt very contained
100 right like
um the character and it's so funny when
he was in that I think I want to say
this like 15 years ago they were taught
before Iron Man it came out this was in
the talks and on our show DC movies from
years ago before the pandemic we kept
hearing news that Black Adam were like
no way this film is ever being made
there's no way and we then as it got
closer and closer and we all talked like
the key of this film will come down to
the Rock because he is such a
personality and such a celebrity and
every movie they do that Meme you see
where it's like four pictures of him
with a brown shirt and it's like these
are all four different movies
are playing the same role or same type
with the smolder and the wink and he's
so good at it he's a guy that you just
love watching but Black Adam is a kind
of a tragic character and you're just
like it is going to hinge on his ability
and I have to say from me personally
that was the complete surprise of the
movie for me was how good he was in the
role and I didn't see the smoldering uh
Dwayne Johnson I saw teth Adam this
fully fledged out character vector
a lot of the movie around him had some
rock eccentricities of Dwayne Johnson
and sativity extensive I don't know I'm
not even saying there it is there it is
you know like the pop music that gets
thrown in I think they're regretting the
Kanye West choice in this film like at
one point but for him me him I thought
he did the character complete Justice
yeah I thought he did too and and I did
see I think it was at the very end of
the film when he's decided not to
rule but to protect
there was something that changed in
either the makeup or the look where I
was like oh that's the rock but for the
rest of it to me he was Black Adam which
actually leads me into my next question
and that is sort of the way that this
film was set up the very beginning when
we you know they did do the prologue the
5 000 years ahead I heard some people
complain about this and in conduct
where we meet the Father and Son which
you know was later revealed that you
know you think he is or maybe you're
meant to believe he was the son but he
is ends up being the father in the
equation
um
just sort of how you felt about that
opener because I thought it was touching
and heartbreaking like I I love the
world that they built and I thought I
really felt for both characters I
thought they set it up in a beautiful
way there was yes was their Exposition
yes did there have to be yes
and I loved the reveal of him when he
finally you see the him as
not Black Adam yet he doesn't have his
name yet but the cloak and the hood like
the first reveal of him I was like
What's it gonna be and it was so like I
was like whoa that's like he's not the
rock he's Black Adam how did you feel
about sort of the way they set up this
film and the opening sequence
Nikki I know you said I know I said I
was kind of in the middle but the way
you even highlight stuff I think this
will change my score higher because I
thought about this like going and again
you're trying to disassociate everything
that goes forward everyone's like oh
it's so rushed at the beginning this was
this and then it doesn't slow down it's
like but okay so would you have rather
gotten a movie where this was the entire
movie and he becomes Black Adam at the
end you're like how many some films we
see that and it ruins the movie you're
like he just becomes the hero in his
costume at the very end it's an origin
story they got it I thought it was a
concise you like you said you feel for
him going on this journey from the
beginning and I was completely fooled
into the switch like I figured they were
doing the classic you know the kid dies
and or the kid gets reborn is is teth
Adam
um
but so I thought that worked so well I
didn't feel rushed I I feel we got
everything we needed to to set up I
think it might have been a little
jarring for people to jump into conduct
present day with inter gang taking over
everything and there was real no kind of
it's there a little bit and inner gang
is kind of a it's not even a deep cut
it's more of a Superman
um mob that's in Metropolis but I went
on board I was like okay it's inner gang
you know they're they're there for the
the mineral that's there and that powers
their vehicles and that's their weapons
so they're you know they're they're a
mob and terrorist outfit so
of course they would go there so but I
thought the setup of the beating was
great I had no problems with it yeah I
mean if you had spent too long like you
said how long would we have waited to
actually see the rock on screen right
like you you want to see him fairly soon
in the mail in the movie right like
otherwise it would be like 30 40 minutes
before the rock appears and that's all
you would have heard people complain
about oh it took 40 minutes to get to
him so I think they did a really nice
job of setting it up I thought it was
super emotional I thought it was a a
great family story and I know I think
from the comics there is sort of an
element of that character and sort of it
they were true to the comics in in that
in that sense
um but I wanted and this is jumping
ahead a little bit people are also
commenting about the shrunken DJ when
they sh when he shrinks back when he's
you know in his size and people are
saying his head was the same size and I
heard people say and that his body was
small I heard people say that before I
saw the film I I have to disagree I
thought his head it was shrunk a little
bit
I don't think it was quite as big as it
normally is but again I really felt for
his character like it was really
you know it was sort of similar to how I
felt about the first Captain America
when you see him sort of smaller and
sort of you know not at his not at his
best that you really I felt for The Rock
in a different way than I have before
again yeah I I thought like I I enjoy
the rock I think he's the kind of guy
that I would love to talk movies with
and sit down and have dinner with
um so I'm never not gonna have a good
time at his movies whether they're there
for me like the Fast and Furious films
are really not for me
um but he has a whole generation of
audience goers that love those so for me
to see him come into the DC Universe my
big thing was like oh I just hope or not
he's not going to turn and we'll see the
the eyebrow raising even with the kids
like you gotta have a catchphrase you
got to do this they played it so under
like an undertone and they they really
downplayed it which it could have gone
over the top with it yeah and they
didn't they left it this I don't say a
tragic character but it was in a sense
where he knows he's he's not a hero and
it's the whole fight within and but he
also sees these people and and that he
wants to protect and how much his world
has changed so again the big like
question mark of this film was going to
be him but he turned out to be a a joy
for me and I I loved it I loved him in
the role and I cannot wait to see more
of him in the role yeah I think if they
had done the humor you know and it could
have they could have really gone could
have gone for it with that naming him
and the catchphrases and even him with
the kid being in the bedroom and like
him being like a fanboy and having all
the stuff in the background they could
have made all these jokes and then
people would have said oh they're trying
to be like Marvel
oh there you go yeah that would have
happened and they didn't there was the
humor but it wasn't haha funny right it
was just there but they didn't it wasn't
sort of the sticking point of the movie
the movie didn't rely on the humor the
one thing that I will say overall that I
I literally had to watch a couple of
breakdowns by people who are
you know like looking for Easter eggs
because there was a few plot points that
I did sort of Miss that was were a
little confusing but they were
introducing a lot in this movie so there
was some stuff that I was like confused
about did you overall follow the story
or were there any moments that you were
like huh wait what well this was like
one of those ones after the theater last
night and I was at work and I had time
to digest it and they do cram a lot in
and and particularly with the JSA so
you're sitting there in the JSA in the
comics is more in in the way that they
do the time on it it's more in the 30s
and 40s and then they were precursors to
the Justice League but so when this was
first announced I thought oh are they
doing a period piece is this going to be
in the 30s or 40s but they made it
current day and then we meet the Justice
League and they're working with Waller
which is a little like Waller to me has
now become kind of nebulous in the DCU
because everyone's working with her and
yeah he runs the suicide squad and she's
not really a good person so I don't see
them working with her but maybe she's a
government she's the government liaison
to
the superhero world and I get that um
but we meet the Justice League and it
was cool but the little the nod too with
um Adam Smasher and the original Adam
Smasher Adam Al Pratt which is Henry
Winkler which I thought that was really
cool
a nice little nod to the legacy of that
yeah but then we're like oh now we meet
cyclone and now we meet this and they're
all together so I'm like and I know you
can't spend time on them it's not their
movie but I would have liked to have
seen a little more
how is this JSA operating it seemed like
him and Dr Freight hadn't been together
for a while
um but we we meet him real quick he
didn't get into the mission and again
it's not their film so I got that but as
a fan I'm kind of like all right I'd
like to see a little more of them well
let's yeah let's dive into talking more
about the JSA because they were actually
my favorite part of the film
I thought first of all first and
foremost before we dive into the
characters the costuming in this film
was excellent I thought the colors Dr
Fate's helmet you know hawkman's wings I
thought
all of it Adam Smasher the effects was
brilliant like it instantly made me
interested and I don't know a ton about
these characters and didn't know a ton
about them before this film I instantly
became interested in them part of it was
their performances but I think costuming
should be nominated for an Oscar for
this film and it will never it will
never get nominated
but it should be it would like I noticed
in the credits I have to look it up it's
it's two first names it was like a Duo
that does these and I was gonna say I've
never seen them before in a film uh but
the costumes you're right they were
fantastic like
um I mean fate could look a little hokey
if you if you wanted to but it didn't I
was like how they gonna do Hawkman they
did it great
um cyclone and Adam Smasher even black
Adam's costume so yeah the costumes were
great I thought their effects work with
them yes it was fantastic I know a lot
of people were when we first saw in a
trailer or commercial they showed Dr
fayton how they did the kind of thing
was Pierce Brosnan's face in a helmet
and like oh it's Iron Man with the heads
up and I'm like I'm like I get the uh
the you know the comparison but it was
they only did that once in that film
which was great
um but I thought yeah the costume work
was fantastic in this film and I think
that's why a lot of people are coming
out of this film saying they want to see
a GSA movie and so 1000 yeah that was
the case they they 100 did a great job
because they sold them on these
characters coming back again okay so
let's go through each of them well first
of all first I want to ask you uh-huh
if you got to have a solo movie of one
of the four characters from this film
not not Black Adam obviously but the
four JSA characters
whose story would you want to see first
oh I'm torn because right off the top of
my head it's either fate or uh Hawkman
same because Hawkman and it was
interesting with this characterization
Hawkman has such a great character where
he's reincarnated over and over so
there's always been different iterations
of him and this one they're playing they
play the kind of more the angry ACT
first think later guy who I'm more
partial to as a run recently I believe
his name was Robert findetti and Brian
hitch did like a 12 issue great story
encompassing his confusing history into
12 issues he's more of a scholar he's an
archaeologist so that's the version I
like so going into this once I saw it
wasn't that I kind of kind of had to
adjust okay but all the touch was great
so to see him I would love to see him
kind of in this
story through the ages of discovering
his other you know Hawk Girl or Hawk
woman is his kind of soul mate and
they're always kind of missing each
other in time and their lives they have
to kind of reconnect and I think that
would be a phenomenal story to tell did
you like the sort of hinted romance
between
like Adam Smasher and Cyclone did you
appreciate that like did you for me I
have to say this like going in I knew I
knew eldest Hodge a new Pierce Brosnan
of course so yeah Noah centrino I
believe his name I'm mispronounced
yeah so I had no idea who this kid is
and then about two years ago he got cast
in everything he was cast in like a
Masters of the Universe movie that never
went anywhere I'm like who is this kid
that now they're throwing in these big
things I was like I don't know this kid
so the He-man ever came through and I
don't know anything else he's been in so
he to me was the great
um surprise of this film like I would
say of course Pierce Brosnan would be my
favorite but seeing him and his
interactions with all of them and then I
know I kind of got in a little argue
with my girlfriend about this because I
like the him and Cyclone stuff in this
like they were small scenes they were
just small little character scenes but
they just worked for me and his kind of
nativity and earnestness in his
performance like just when he's walking
up with a bucket of chicken eating and
Dr Faye kind of makes disappearance like
not now like it's those little moments
he never overplayed it but I was this
guy this actor won me over as a fan on
this role and what he did with so little
dialogue so I I agree with you he
reminded me a little bit of when we
first saw Chris Pratt in Guardians of
the Galaxy that little bit of a
goofiness that doofy energy that you
enjoy him he's just fun to watch he
doesn't overdo it he knows how to play
the humor and I don't wanna
do I want to call him out I don't know I
think in the I think in Justice League
like the flash character they they made
him do too much like you could tell they
were probably on set going more jokes
improvise do more and it was too much
right yeah in this case nothing was sort
of overdone in terms of who he was I did
appreciate the the snacking I mean that
said
of the four
he would be the last one whose origin
story I'd want to see first I thought
Pierce was amazing I thought his Doctor
Fate was so interesting but it also
makes sense because Doctor Strange is
probably my favorite Marvel character
yeah so I love the sort of sorcerer
aspect of it the person who's super
smart that can Vision has a vision but I
thought he was
as you know he's just like that
character and that performance could
have gone very wrong
oh a hundred percent yeah and it's so
funny because again with my girl I love
seeing these movies with my girlfriend
because she's not attached to him like I
am like there's no she's no
um barometer to judge superhero films
and she doesn't know the history so she
just goes in to enjoy them and she's
like oh so he's kind of like doctor
strange huh yeah after my glasses well
actually uh Dr Fate came first and this
and this and right so in the comics he
came right yes yes
um she's like oh I didn't know that so
and it kind of went into like DC and
Marvel for every Marvel or DC characters
there's a counterpart in DC there's
Hawkeye in Green Arrow you know so and
just kind of going through the history
of comics with her and and how the two
companies at the time would compete but
I agree like and she's just like I don't
care he came first second that and she
says I don't know if Nick you might know
what this word is I don't know what it
is the smize she's like they've got the
smirk but he's got the smize and I is it
a smirk and a smile
um yes this is from the Tyra Banks
School of modeling okay that's from
America's Next Top Model and smizing is
is when you kind of like you smile with
your eyes so smile eyes so it's like
okay yeah she's got she's got so she
thought Pierce oh she's all about Fierce
I think they all smized to be honest
yeah they uh yeah I think they all got
it down except maybe Aldis because he
was a little more brooding as you said
yeah
he was so
so good in this he was such a and this
is one thing I will say to your point as
well about Noah's performance
um is it Joan Colette Sarah is that how
you pronounce his first name Jones I
thought it was Jimmy okay thank you I
could be completely wrong because I know
we talked a lot about it with my other
co-host when this was all announced and
someone came on and they yeah
Sarah who is the director who directed
Jungle Cruise yeah and he who directed
the shallows with Blake Lively and what
I think he does well and what you uh you
know sometimes in superhero movies we
don't see is real acting so when you
were talking about those Quiet Moments
between the two of them he allows his
actors to really act so even though it's
a superhero movie there was all of the
JSA had strong performances nothing was
sort of cliche or like surface level you
felt these characters had a history you
felt they had a history with each other
you felt there was an emotional depth to
all of them and they did they were
allowed to sort of have those acting
moments with the acting like especially
with the kid like oh he's a kid this and
I was like I actually really like the
kid like and he was just he wasn't like
the overbearing precocious look at me
I'm gonna be wink cute for the audience
I I really enjoyed him and I I'm gonna
say that and not many people are talking
about it but the performance for me I
think that was the best overall acting
performance of film was Sarah Shahi like
I thought and maybe she didn't have the
the flashy role she wasn't a superhero
or anything but I thought her
performance
was the foundation for this entire film
and I didn't realize how big a part she
was going to have in it and I thought
her acting as this kind of freedom
fighter but a mother
um just grounded and brought all the
other pieces together as she was kind of
like the central uh Hub on that wheel
that brought everyone together so the
Sun
Eamon the character Eamon that's who you
were talking about with the kid yeah
yeah Eamon was a kid I think I think you
know like the skateboarding stuff didn't
really work and how he kept getting away
from the sort of the Guard yeah I guess
it was okay it was a little Back to the
Future but but
I actually am going to disagree about
Sarah okay the love please I didn't
I felt like part of it was that she had
so much Exposition dialogue um
it was on her shoulders to explain a lot
of the film with her dialogue
and that's a tough gig
I mean you probably know this as an
actor
those sort of lines when you're given
those lines where you're given like it
has sort of you're you're talking but it
has nothing to do with the story you're
telling the story without acting out the
story maybe you can speak to that how
hard it is
but yeah he didn't love her character
and I didn't necessarily think some of
that Side Story was necessary like when
the towards the end when the zombies
yeah calling them zombies happened and
the kid was like getting his people
United to fight the zombies I was like
this looks like it's gonna be like
they're gonna break into a flash mob
dance like in the Town Square like
they're all gonna do the Thriller you
know it was a little bit like I don't
know I don't know if we needed to see
them
throughout at that point and then they
kept meeting up with the JSA no matter
where they were in the city like they
just ran into them all the time like how
did that happen like it just seemed a
little contrived so I don't maybe
necessarily think it was her fault but I
didn't love her character
it's tough because and maybe that's why
she's not being as mentioned in all the
reviews and all the people talking about
the film because maybe they did have a
problem with it I think for me uh the
exposition dumps are always tough when
you're doing dialogue especially when
you're talking about you know conduct
and
eternium and all these different
minerals and and stuff but for me it's
like and I I get why the filmmakers
needed that it's the audiences or what
they think is the audience's eye into
the world yeah I I always look back in
the Old Masters of the Universe Dolph
Lundgren movie it's like you want to go
see He-Man and Skeletor fight and then
what's Courtney Cox doing popping up in
there and her boyfriend that works at a
chicken joint but the audience is like
we got to have the audience
see themselves in this movie in some way
and this is their key to get into this
world so it's such a tough so she's
fighting like three battles she's got
the dialogue she's got trying to be the
audience's eyes and then trying to be a
fully fleshed out character in that
World
um
so I definitely seen that that could be
why people aren't talking about the role
as much maybe they were like every time
she pops up here comes Exposition yeah
you know and I do like for me and you
brought up the zombies that was the one
I'm kind of like oh we're doing zombies
now yeah I know he's the dead and he can
wake the dead or he's part of the
underworld but I guess they needed an
army to fight you know I think you know
it wasn't horrible it just was a little
bit
um I thought they were gonna do the
Thriller dance for sure
like I thought they're all of a sudden
all gonna be and then she and the kid
we're gonna
we're gonna be fine at the hands of the
triangles up doing it
I mean they're definitely
one and they're setting up she becomes
his love interest later on and doesn't
he give some of the power his powers to
the kid later on it's the family yeah
and they kind of do a dynamic with uh
kind of the Shazam family where it's the
families a lot of guys are saying
they're complaining about the character
and and why do we need a Black Adam I
mean he really didn't come into
significance until there's a series
called 52 and it's like a weekly series
back in like I want to say it's 2006
2007. oh wow and since then he kind of
took over and it makes sense because it
around the time the rock probably had
gotten invested in the character you
know he saw this character come into
popularity and comics and said oh I can
play that that'll be great for me
um but yeah I believe she turns into
Isis I could be completely wrong on that
I'm trying to think of because again the
character was never really something
that I gravitated to uh but then the sun
also becomes this kind of
I don't want to say family but this unit
of uh together and he falls in love with
her and and so they are setting that up
and I want to say that she played his
wife in the movie in the flashbacks I
thought that was her
when they talk about her at the
beginning and she's kind of covered up
with the they they covered her up with
the shawl it was kind of like her I was
like oh I think that's her you thought
it was Sarah Shahi I think so oh I could
be wrong I could be wrong interesting
but I could have sworn once they had him
revealed and it was him like with big
head and skinny body as people were
saying and they did that quick shot of
the wife I was like I thought that's her
but I could be wrong I could be
completely wrong no but that would be an
interesting little twist yeah they were
the the original family and and she was
and I don't know if that was a nod like
to the comics and people are saying hey
we know what's gonna happen with them
we're just teasing the connection is
there or I could be completely wrong and
it's a different actress I want to give
a shout out to Jalen Christian who
played heroot who is The Rock's son yeah
who I thought did a really nice job and
as well and I apologize I'm reading
these names but Muhammad Amir who played
the brother who was kind of the comic
relief and you know there was a little
bit of like when they first went into
the the Tomb in the opener When Sarah's
character goes in and he's sitting in
the van and what was the song that was
playing and then it played again later
Rick Astley Never Gonna Give You Up was
it yeah it might have been it but I was
like oh I've seen this before in movies
I saw it in stranger things like the kid
with the pizza kid in the van this past
season like I've seen this before we
he's sitting there with his headphones
on and then something happens and I was
like oh don't do that we've seen that
before but then I was like oh but I
actually love him and we must protect
him at all costs like through the whole
movie like when he got
hurt I was like no no and I was glad
that he he was okay but yeah
I'm sorry no I was gonna say like I
really I love personally because we I
see so many movies I like seeing
unknowns I like seeing fresh new faces I
like in terms of representation I
thought it was really great and I just
thought it was just refreshing to see
these new people and I want to see more
of them and they did a good job so it
that hats off to them for holding their
own
yeah he he I loved him I remember in the
trailer they showed that scene at the
van I'm like oh it's just gonna be like
the annoying sidekick comedy relief yes
but he wasn't because he was very
heartfelt like again these like the
humor worked for me and it got you know
wasn't like laugh out loud crying humor
but it was subtle in certain places but
that character and again I've never seen
him before in anything and I enjoyed him
like he's like you know you don't die
you die by electricity he's like I'm an
electrician like somebody yeah yeah it's
great and I yeah I really enjoyed his
character okay so let's talk about
um the meat of the film and that is the
action which I think a lot of people
agree that the action was done really
really well they're like oh you know
when The Rock signed on to do this he
was gonna bring it
and they certainly did I thought that
the fight the first fight between Black
Adam and the JSA was like and you see
their powers and Adam Smasher when he's
like
you know gets big and it's a great way
to describe it the only thing I wasn't
100 sure about was the choice of colors
for cyclone like it took me a second to
get used to sort of seeing how you know
her whatever you want to call it was all
these sort of colors that reminded me a
little bit of morbius if you remember
morbius like I was like oh no is that
what we're doing again yeah but then
then I was like no I see why they did it
it was probably a tough choice of sort
of how to visualize that but I don't
know if that's a comic thing too if that
was sort of always her colors
with Cyclone I I believe so I'm not as
familiar with her uh because from what I
remember she's a descendant of Red
Tornado yeah and they talk they they
again that was one of those things they
talk about Nanobots and fixing the guy
and they're watching him fit and she's
like banana Bots are her and that makes
her powers I'm like oh they're they're
really going through this one faster
speeds so I thought and again I'm
looking at it from like okay so they're
in conduct it's out Browns yellows
oranges they've got a fate is yellow yes
so you got that in there oh yeah you've
got to get some color going and she
brought that that green pop with her
suit so yeah I'm not sure what the
colors I don't know if it's kind of like
with her hair and her suit the green
it's like a showing like a trailing off
of it so it's like the the color spin
um but as far as the action goes like
I've got to say like a lot of times
we're thrown out like oh the CGI and
some scenes like I don't know because
from the beginning we understand where
this world is and the character but
there was never any standout bad CGI for
me
um I thought the moments of I know
people didn't like the slow-mo a lot but
I thought those were used sparingly and
done really well I thought a great
integration of the CGI with their powers
and the world
you didn't think I did the slo-mo didn't
stand out to me in any negative way I
mean I guess the argument is that the
third act which I like they didn't
belabor it it wasn't a super long third
act they kind of made the second act the
bulk of the fun action between the JSA
and Black Adam and then you know and
then as they team up later
um I loved watching them fight and sort
of interact with each other and work
together uh but I didn't think
I hate it when the third Act is too long
and two and you know what's gonna happen
and I didn't do that but it was CG heavy
for sure it was yeah I wasn't mad at it
yeah it was you know the entire thing
was CJ but it wasn't to me bad like like
you like oh they had to that is that's a
pickup shot that they added and they
didn't have the money to finish like it
just all as a very seamless film to me
maybe because this film has been in the
works for so long but I feel exactly
like you like I knew at one point where
Black Adam kind of resigns himself to
the Justice Society and then like oh
wait a minute there's that shot in the
trailer of him being put in a water
coffin or whatever's like we haven't
seen that yet it's like and I know sabak
is in this well we got a third act
coming but then once it got going it got
going and didn't let up so I think
I would have I I don't know if we needed
sabak I know I don't I don't I think if
it would have just been the JSA versus
The Rock I think it would have been a oh
interesting yeah if we there but it
needed to be different resolutions at
the end but I think it would have been a
stronger film without that tertiary
character in there
yeah because it was it wasn't a strong
enough yeah it was kind and it's not
like it's the Joker you know you're
saving for the third act or something
yeah Sabaka gnomes clamoring to see him
in a film as far as I know my apologies
to any subac fans out there
but it was cool and you know it was done
well
but he's a cool death yeah very cool and
and yes very cool death and it set up
the ending there so hey you know you so
you kept moving under two hours and you
had a great three act you know
film so I don't think it wasn't like
this film was two and a half hours
you're like man come on you need to trim
this thing down
so I have a question okay why
did Amanda Waller
I think the suicide squad together when
she had the JSA already that to me I
think he went like yesterday when I'm
sitting there trying to kind of talk
talk about what we'll we'll talk about
I'm like
I don't understand and I think they're
trying to make Viola Davis like the
Samuel L Jackson of the DCU where she
connects them all and I get that I think
it's a strong choice and she brings it
every time she shows up
but they need to let us know like okay
she's the government liaison with
superheroes but she's also running this
black site task force acts that no one
knows about because the way it's set
she's working with Hawkman they're going
over the profiles of all the characters
there's no way they would work with them
if they knew they were also working with
the suicide squad and right awful
villains so I think we needed to
establish or do need to establish
somewhere where Waller is kind of like
the real world government face of
superhero
um kind of like in the MCU at what
general Ross was he was the government
guy but I'm the liaison to superheroes
she's the liaison to deal with the
Justice League with Superman she'll talk
to them on the government's behalf but
also even most people in the government
don't know I've got this little black
ops program but then they've got secret
prisons in the Arctic so she's got a
budget so
yeah there's a lot there that and again
that wasn't this was not the movie to
explain that I get that yeah there was a
lot to there was a lot to do and and I
think maybe also the stuff that she
sends the suicide squad to do is beneath
the jsa's pay grade of course they're
like sorry or not right
he's not right by just think audience
members and I think that's why they're
like oh the DC is so messy and I get the
problems people have with with what WB
is trying to do with DC we just need
this kind of
framework like what are the rules that
with this world we're playing in you
know Waller is a great character she's
in Viola Davis is a great catch as an
actress to have in that role just let us
know
she's working with both teams but both
the teams don't know about everything
that's going on because yeah the Justice
Society would shut that down in a
heartbeat so is that the question you
thought I was going to ask
you said oh I think no no just the
messiness of it I 100 oh okay because
for me it was like okay the pieces are
there the JSA is there task force x is
there and okay now she's working with
the Justice League again let me know
what this
framework is give us give us the
building blocks you know let us know
yeah so so here's my second big question
that I I'm confused about why did Dr
Fate
need to go into the building at that
particular moment because he went to
sacrifice himself
did he really need to go in in that
particular juncture because nothing was
happening at that moment like why
couldn't he just wait
I'm kind of like because and again they
were tiptoeing against Marvel with the
end game where Doctor Strange knew knew
all the outcomes and so he knew so magic
is always so tricky in films It's like
because you're like well why don't you
just do this you're a magic why didn't
you just you know erase thanos's memory
and like so it's so tough and like my
only thought was because he knew the
outcome had to happen that particular
way he saw Hawkman dying but he knew it
was going to be him and and on the other
hand I I think it's safe to say that
he's not really dead because his Essence
will live with on in the helmet
um because there's no way you kill off
Pierce Brosnan and not have him back for
a secret you just don't do it what I was
gonna say did I spoil it or something
I'm just like no I mean this is spoiler
discussion but here's my question he's
so good in it you know he he's cool to
do more movies not doing Bond right now
he's cool to do it he's got time his
careers you know he's he's working a lot
but like this is a great move so why did
they have to kill him off like I did did
someone just have to die in this like it
kind of seemed like you know if you're
gonna kill off a major character in The
JSA earn it do it down the road did it
need to happen is my question because
now if we're gonna have him in well yes
like you said anything can happen
there's magic and all these things but
now are we gonna have to see go back and
do a prequel which I'd be fine with to
go back to and do a prequel but isn't
going to be a different age and I don't
know I just all of that Nikki that
brings up to the point of it being
confusing like okay are you gonna do a
prequel great
but is that going to confuse everything
with these characters we just met like
I'm kind of curious in the thought of of
the of the script phase and writing of
it because there's always a
um I don't want to say it's not a it's
it always seems like the person of color
is the one that dies yeah in these and
like there's a lot of flack that andor's
getting right now this last step two
episodes ago were the two great uh
character deaths were people of color
and and did they see and go okay well
this we we know that will be a problem
going forward do we shift or did they
just say this felt the story because I
was kind of I knew Hawkman wasn't going
to die but then when they were teasing
him I'm like oh they're going to prevent
his death
so I don't know if they were behind the
scenes Talk happening during the
production phase like well Aldous Hodge
was cast so once that role was cast with
the man of color okay we we're not
killing off Hawkman
or like you know that that's the pieces
of puzzle that to take to make a movie
and the choices that happen you never
know uh but all of such I know he's a
younger actor dude we want to see more
movies with him where his fate is at the
end of his career he makes the choice to
die we're not going to kill off Adam
Smasher Cyclone because they're new
you know right I don't know if it ever
came between the two of them and maybe
different script versions had Hawkman
dying I don't see that I don't see them
killing him off
um I mean it might have been like Pierce
might have been like yeah I'll come back
and do this movie as a one-off and we
didn't they didn't realize they were
going to get lightning in a bottle like
he was yeah he's so fantastic and it
would be something that people would
want to see more of because he is an
older character and also then it just
goes like well we can always bring him
back because of magic and he'll he could
be the voice inside the helmet you know
that his his soul is trapped in the in
the in the helmet which is hap you know
that's that happened throughout all of
comics so I think maybe they're looking
at that like we've got in our back
pocket we don't know how they're gonna
react but I think the minute he was cast
there was everyone was 100 behind that
casting with him so uh before we move on
to the big elephant in the room that is
Henry Cavill Superman returning in the
mid credits uh favorite or least
favorite moment that anything else that
we sort of haven't dove into I guess for
me the the underlying was the surprise
of Atom Smasher
that I was really just not even invested
in him at all going into this film and
now and that I I have to say I'll go
from a big swing it's a rock I don't
show up to every movie that he does uh I
love him as a person and as a celebrity
but he's not someone that I have to
see the name the new Rock movie when it
comes out or the new Dwayne Johnson
movie but for me because he was the big
elephant in the room like is this is he
going to have a fully fledged character
that makes me forget the world of Dwayne
Johnson and 100 did that so yeah those
were my two big surprises as far as the
weakest thing
probably the villain sebok at the end it
was just kind of an afterthought for me
switch and sort of having the visual
switch about of the villain yeah like I
know it was him but right it was just
having it I think maybe if he would we
had seen him more
yeah visually I thought he was fine but
yeah it was kind of a switch and yeah
I'm trying to think
yeah I think
nothing really I mean I think a couple
of there was a couple corny moments and
and that's another thing that people
talked about the movie feeling very like
early 2000s but I don't I love that era
maybe that's why I enjoyed it so much I
was thinking I think it's like maybe
like a lot of those music beats that it
threw in all of a sudden but I have to
say like Dwayne Johnson knows audiences
and they knows what they love of his
film so I think
he knows what they come to see and he's
he's such a lover of movies and a lover
of audiences and wanting to please his
audience and I think those beats were
thrown in because he knows they like
those in those movies with him
so he's trying to give them everything
he is and and he's speaking of
everything he did this thing during the
lead up to this film where he all but
told everybody that Superman was going
to show up in this and he has even
talked about I saw an interview where
somebody asked him about is it Barry
Keegan who played um Joker in the Batman
is that his name yeah I I think you're
super I'm not going to try to pronounce
it but I think you're pronouncing it
right I will not try it but yes
he said something like oh interesting
that you liked him stay tuned and it's
just like he's he's playing his hand
he's showing everybody's hand kind of I
think he's so eager to tease that I
think he should pull back a little bit
um so
I I I'll just ask first like how did you
feel about the Henry Cavill moment
because I can't contain myself it's it's
one of those things like I love Cavill
in the role I I love Man of Steel one
I'm an avid anyone that knows me
especially even on Rotten Tomatoes like
I was on the Rotten Tomatoes was wrong
about Batman versus Superman I love that
film
I love Snyder's take on these characters
so for him I never felt like he was gone
I figured like there's something going
on the whole WB Discovery everything BS
something's going on but he's always
said he's like I don't I still have the
cape and his agents are always like he's
still Superman until they say otherwise
I hate that it was put out there I know
a lot of people are saying that they
needed to put that out there because the
movie wasn't tracking well
I think people would have gone to see
this movie regardless because of the
Rock and then if when you find out what
was in it I think Word of Mouth would
have built
so I think that it was like with the no
way home we all knew Toby mogar and
Andrew Garfield were in this film they
never said it but we all knew they were
in this yeah you couldn't hide from that
even if you wanted to avoid anything on
the internet we knew they were in it
when they showed up though it was still
incredible
wow so Mr Cavill has never had a finer
Moment On Screen IMO in my opinion those
10
th gold silver bronze
all of the metals and all of the all of
the DC Universe it was phenomenal the
curl High the curl is back or there for
the first time for him he looked amazing
he looked a little older than we've seen
him before as he is it has been since
2013 since we saw had a You Know a Man
of Steel movie but he looked more like
Superman than I've ever seen him look
like he looked phenomenal his cheekiness
the way he delivered the line I was like
that sir is a movie star that ladies and
gentlemen is a movie star
congratulations worth the price of
admission right there 100 like I mean
you know it's coming you know they've
Amanda Waller drone flies in there we
all know what's coming at this point but
then the John Williams theme kind of
does a little John Williams and like I
did my I got little goosebumps in it
because it's he's so good in the role he
doesn't get it in and everyone out there
whether you hate Zack Snyder in his
films or or you don't like Henry or you
don't like what they did with the
character everyone wants Henry Cavill
for another film they all like give him
Man of Steel too yeah they want that so
I think the rock he I mean and now he
reports they were planning to film that
Cameo without the head it was just going
to be the pot like they did with Shazam
I'm like are you out of your mind you
don't do that if you can't get Henry
Cavill back because I think that was
everyone's like what's going on with DC
this and that I think the rock was kind
of like we got it we're finally getting
there we're gonna do we're listening to
audiences so I think that is a great
feeling to have to know that Cavill is
back hopefully they're gonna do another
movie get him a solo film uh but it was
just he's great in the role I think
you know and it's it's tough because WB
is in a tough spot you know it's it
there are a very vocal fandom that love
him in that role and you know with the
Snyder cut and all that they came
forward and
you know whether people want to say it
or not and maybe this is a bad take with
me as long as Henry Cavill is in the
role of Superman whether you give him a
spit curl put John Williams or put a red
and blue bright suit the DNA of Zack
Snyder is still there so it kind of sat
you know we're not getting the Snyder
verse that everyone wanted with his
Justice League two and three that's not
gonna happen but you're still getting
the world that he created so I think
it's kind of The Best of Both Worlds
where it's going in a New Direction but
honoring the past you what's the saying
you respect the past honor the past but
respect the future or vice versa where
it's like yeah you're getting the Best
of Both Worlds you're getting this Zack
Snyder created character but it's going
to be taken a different direction with
the same actor so yeah I mean the suit
was brighter that everybody started
about yeah like it did have you know the
original imprint but it also felt very
it it felt like he had evolved and it
felt like oh where you've been I want to
know what's going on you know obviously
we want to see more of him 100 so so
oh here was my question okay in my
theater
I would say half the people in my
theater got up
and left before the caval thing and I
was like are you nuts what rock have you
been living under because
what did you just go okay we're gonna go
to a movie should we go see over here
The Rock's in a new movie do they have
no understanding like how do you get up
and not watch it well I I've Had A New
Perspective on that like the Marvel
films have kind of trained audiences to
expect a post-credits scene and I was in
a couple DC films where there wasn't one
and people like oh that's a missed
opportunity
where as in I remember in Black Panther
uh watching that film and and oh I'd say
over half the audience got up at the end
credits before the post credits and and
my friend the University's like yeah
like remember this is this film is
bringing audiences that have never seen
superhero films before they're finally
being represented so they're not used to
an MCU film where we're getting this so
you have to remember that and so with
the rock I don't know if his films do a
lot of post credit so
could be that half the audiences were
just there they didn't care and I saw an
exit poll it was a majority of the
people were there for the film because
it was a Dwayne Johnson film not because
it was a DC film yes and they were so
I'm like okay so they're not used to his
films having post-credit scenes they're
not used to a superhero film or what
comes they're just for the Dwayne
Johnson movie he doesn't do Post credits
there's no reason to stick around so
yeah my audience a lot not a lot is a
few
um but again I saw a Sunday morning and
it's not really the most energetic crowd
yeah so yeah it was interesting but I I
expect that unless it's more even in
Marvel films I still see people get up
and walk and I'm like what do you got
there's been 23 of these we're gonna get
five more post credits what are you guys
doing but I know it gets it does there
is always too much of a good thing uh so
let's talk about as we wrap wrap up the
conversation let's talk about the future
of Black Adam of
the Justice Society of dceu in general
like if if you had your choice like what
do you think should come next what
should be the next film in this well
it's we're certainly we're such in a
weird place because all these films are
done all these films The Flash Aquaman
you know Blue Beetle yeah where we're
supposed to know what's going to be
happening with the DCU like apparently
the flash is the one that kind of sets
everything on the course
of what's going forward but do we know
that now I mean Black Adam I believe was
always supposed to come out before the
Flash
Black Adam was supposed to originally
come out in 2019 I believe okay yeah so
it was always before the flash or 20
maybe it was 2021 but it was It was
supposed it was it did get delayed Nikki
I have always been DC's most vocal
supporter and champion and and to to
much to my detriment online about that
but I'm even in a place right now like I
don't know what's going on I I I like I
loved the Batman but I know that's
completely separate
from what I'm hearing the flash is
phenomenal like I've heard a lot of
people kind of and I and I never go
online with like oh my sources say this
because I don't put myself out there
like that but I'm hearing around we're
Rankin in Los Angeles that the flash is
just phenomenal and and there I think
there's a reason why they're sticking
with Miller through it like they know
they've got a good film on their hands
they know that where it ends and what it
sets up
so for me I'm kind of in a wait and see
place I I would love to and I know
people are clamoring for Shazam or for
Black Adam and Superman but it's like
him and Shazam need to that needs to
happen
the two of them because that's the big
um fun of the of those characters when
those kind of Worlds Collide and it
seems like with uh Fury of the Gods the
next Shazam film that they're really
going into the gods and and bringing
that world so much bigger than the first
one and I think the the Black Adam would
be a real because they I mean Shazam has
said in Black Adam but they never
mention the champion of Shazam
yeah and in the first Shazam they did
talk about the champion
and it was kind of a bald guy with robes
so there's the light connectivity but
this film seemed like to not want to
even address that out but German hansu
the wizard was there so
it's connectivity but not in a and they
said Shazam a lot yeah it's there it's
there the the DNA is there
I just don't know how to go forward
we I don't know if another Black Adam
Solo movie is necessary I think you've
got a full team with Shazam it ha I
think it has to be down the road yeah I
think I personally Man of Steel too
absolutely doesn't have to be called
that obviously but you need that before
you need anything else now I agree with
what you're saying about the flash I've
heard the same thing I think that is
going to be the connective tissue that
people are saying is missing and sort of
setting up the future I think we need to
catch up with Superman he is a core
character that we have been missing I
know The Rock has teased people have
asked him about the fight with Shazam
versus the fight with Cavill he wants
Black Adam vs Superman because I think
he's thinking box office I think he's
thinking like what's going to be best
for Dwayne Johnson which I don't blame
him for right but I think in terms of
order I would like to see Superman
then I'd be fine with seeing Black Adam
versus Superman then I'd be fine with
the Shazam versus Black Adam but I don't
yeah I don't know about another black
yeah until I see what else happens right
it's so you're 100 and a Man of Steel
Two
would 100 work on its own like you know
just like as the Batman proved I mean
again that was disassociated from what
we've got going on here but people want
capital in the roll I think if it's done
well and you give us a villain that we
haven't seen like a brainiac or
something
um I really think the audiences will be
there for it and you know this world is
set up now you know he like he said I
feel and a little I think people should
feel a little bit better like okay we've
got Camelback now we know who our
Superman is in this world yeah let's go
forward from there
well I want to thank you for joining
this was such oh Before I Let You Go yes
where does this rank in the dceu for you
maybe rank I was yeah I knew you're
going to say that and because I don't
like because I I can't include the
Batman in there because that's not
really part of this
ah it's in the middle to the lower
somehow I'll say this Nikki and I get a
lot of crap for this I am a huge lover
of Wonder Woman 84. so that my ranking
when it comes to like my opinion and
what I love
you know it's very different from
everybody but I have such a love for
that movie uh and I know it's not a
great movie
but there's so you know and I love
Aquaman I love Aquaman oh and I would
never the magic word I would have never
thought in a million years Nikki if you
said here's gonna be the five DC films
you can pick which one do you want to
see Aquaman would have been the last 100
last but I just fell in love with that
character the way that they had so much
fun making the movie and the way that
they said you know what we don't know if
we're ever getting a sequel so we're
gonna give you everything in this film
um so I think time will be kind to me in
this film right now it's kind of mid to
bottom in the DCU it's better than the
better than Suicide Squad the first one
um
yeah but but again that for me is more
on the characters I I there's the
characters were not someone that I'm
attached to on any level outside of yeah
really I mean people give the GC DC and
the DCU Flack but I have to say I loved
Wonder Woman I loved Aquaman I loved Man
of Steel I love so many of these films
that I would put this one kind of upper
mid I would say but that's because there
was a high bar set from me but Aquaman I
think Wonder Woman is a better movie but
Aquaman is still my number one I turn it
on over and over I put on I put it on if
I want to watch a re-watch a superhero
movie and I'm gonna have it on while I'm
cooking that's what I'm putting on
that's myself I enjoy the hell of it
anyway
um Mike I want to thank you so much for
being such an amazing guest and breaking
down Black Adam with me and let people
know where they can find you if I'm here
at all social media at Mike Kalinowski
that's where if you if you if you're new
to talk DC with someone I'm your guy
please feel free to reach out I love
talking about this world
and we love talking about this world and
we love chatting uh with you guys for
you guys so thank you all for tuning in
for this episode of the after show and
we will see you next time bye
[Music]